In my outer electron shell
Lies an electron all by itself
I seek elation
Through oxidation
I have always felt incomplete
One electron shy of eighteen
I’ve the highest
Electron affinity
If we exchange this one electron
We’ll both achieve noble gas config’ration
And we’ll release energy
As ions you’ll see
A bond
Made by metals and non-metals
I’m positive
I’m negative
A force of attraction creates this bond
Made by metals and non-metals
Ionic bonds
Covalent bonds
Metallic, these are the bonds of chemistry
The octet rule says atoms like eight
Electrons in their outermost state.
I’ll share mine with you
I’ll share with you
If we both share these six electrons
We’ll both achieve noble gas config’ration
And we’ll release energy
Covalent there’ll be
A Bond
Electronegativity
Is similar for non-metals
And so,we share this bond of electrons
Electronegativity
Ionic Bonds
Covalent Bonds
Metallic,these are the bonds of chemistry
Free
Electrons all around
Mutual attractive forces abound
In this way
I will stay
Crystalline with you
Our Bond
Ionic bonds
Covalent bonds
Metallic
00:03:52,00:03:02
These are the bonds of chemistry